on a mis un cercueil on a vu une petite
pancarte où l'on dénoncé notre situation
précaire et voilà on a mis ça dans un
cercueil c'est notre âme c'est notre
mort sociale qui est programmée par ce
gouvernement
surtout avec cette nouvelle réforme de
l'assurance chômage s'il est appelé à
être mis en place à partir du 1er
septembre
et ça c'est c'est catastrophique c'est
un désastre social qui se profile dans
le pays
on participe à l'économie du pays de
façon très très active pas plus loin
vous voyez là semble hélas eh ben c'est
nous qui assurons le service là bas aux
thèses agents de sécurité maître d'hôtel
puis signée livreur fleuriste vincee
toutes ces personnes qui travaillent on
comptera qu'on appelle cdd eu là bas
c'est nous et nous on est les oubliés de
la république
tu sais d'intermittents de l'emploi ces
deux millions deux cent mille personnes
de l'intermittence de l'emploi qui
travaille dans l'hôtellerie et
restauration événementielle de façon
directe ou indirecte est qui et qui
malheureusement sans laisser à la marche
de la société que intermittent à séméac
habitants l'emploi intermittents du
spectacle d'accord on ne parle quand on
parle des intermittents ne parle que des
intermittents du spectacle on est 120000
il ya deux millions deux cent mille
personnes qui sont chômeurs catégories b
et c qui sont aussi dans l'intermittence
de l'emploi le gouvernement n'a mis
l'urgence pour prendre en charge tous
ces personnes 2 million deux cent mille
la question c'est non seulement
l'annulation de la réforme d'assurance
chômage du décret du 26 juillet à 2019
qui massacrent le seuil d'ouverture de
droit depuis le 1er novembre qui
massacrerait les allocations payées
septembre mais en plus nous voulons de
nouveau droit nous voulons une
prolongation des droits pour tous ceux
qui sont dans la précarité et le chômage
parce que sinon ils n'ont plus de
ressources
nous sommes dans le même bateau nous
travaillons tous dans la discontinuité
c'est ça qui nous réunit les années de
suite et 10 d'intermittents du spectacle
n'ont pas été créés dont l'art et la
culture
elles ont été créées pour répondre à des
problèmes de discontinuité de l'emploi
parce que nous travaillons comme eux de
manière discontinue
c'est la discontinuité qui au départ est
la base de ce régime spécial
on est face à une catastrophe sociale
avec l'explosion du chômage il ya déjà
cinq cent mille chômeurs de plus au mois
d'avril
et ça ne fait que commencer avec des
plans sociaux et on voit très bien que
ceux qui sont les premiers touchés
ce sont les précaires la variable
d'ajustement est en fait là ce qui va se
passer avec avec cette réforme là ça
veut dire qu'en plus d'avoir déjà six
millions de personnes qui sont privées
d'emploi on va avoir un virgule iii 1.5
millions de personnes qui vont être soit
radiée soit qu'ils vont voir leurs
droits des cendres ça veut dire une
crise sociale d'ampleur ça veut dire
qu'on est en train de tuer l'assurance
chômage dans notre pays
du coup en fait on est en train de
briser la vie de plein de gens et c'est
ça qui ont exprimé aujourd'hui l'action
pour lequel moi je suis venu en soutien
[Musique]